哈嘍 大家好
今天的影片想跟大家聊一個話題
就是怎樣建立一個股票研究和分析的框架
在這個框架當中
基本面分析和圖形分析各自承擔什麼樣的角色
以及如何將這兩個方面結合起來
讓我們的投資邏輯更加的完整
所謂基本面分析框架
簡單來說就是三個方面
商業模式 財務表現 市場定價
所謂商業模式就是說
這家公司做什麼生意
賺誰的錢
是2B（面向企業）的生意
還是2C（面向普通消費者）的生意
賺錢的方式是不是有壟斷性
是不是有護城河
能不能夠讓這個業務無限擴大
它的生意有沒有天花板
所以這些都是我們
做投資最基礎的一些底層邏輯
如果說在五分鐘之內
你無法回答這些問題的話
說明你可能對這家公司的生意無法理解
無法理解的生意
我的看法就是
最好不要碰
我認為一家偉大的公司
它的產品應該具備四個基本條件
第一個 無差別的產品
第二 最廣泛的用戶
第三 自由定價
第四 市場壟斷
最典型的例子就是Google
它的產品是無差別的
你使用的Google和我使用的Google
本質上說沒有任何差別
全球80億人和全球絕大多數的企業
都需要Google的服務
都是它的潛在客戶
Google的產品定價
沒有政府或者某個機構來限制它的價格
Google在很多產品很多服務方面
是具有壟斷特性的
比如說Google的搜索是絕對的壟斷者
此外它的Android系統
Chrome瀏覽器
Google Map
Google Cloud
Gmail
還有就是你現在正在看的YouTube
也是一個絕對性的壟斷產品
所以我認為做投資就要投資這樣的生意
有了這些大概的這種商業認知之後
我們就可以進入第二層
就可以看財務表現
財務表現主要是看三類數據
首先是看收入
包括收入的規模
收入的成長性
然後是看運營利潤率
也就是EBIT margin
它是用來考察企業的核心的盈利能力的
如果說運營利潤是負值
那說明這家企業屬於是結構性的虧損
說明這家企業的商業模式可能存在問題
第三個就是看現金流
現金流包括運營現金流和自由現金流
運營現金流呢
就是說企業在商業運營的過程當中
產生的現金流
自由現金流呢
就是說商業運營過程當中的現金流減去
它的資本支出
那剩下來的部分就是自由現金流
我是比較看重這個自由現金流
因為自由現金流
它才是企業真正賺到的錢
這些多出來的現金流
可以用於擴大它的生產規模
或者說是開發新的產品
或者說是收購其他的企業
或者說用分紅
或者回購股份的方式
來回饋它的股東
這都是可以的
也就是說
具備強大自由現金流的企業
它的生意啊
它的生意的彈性就非常好
可攻可守
我比較喜歡的企業呢
有幾下幾個特徵
你可以記一下
首先第一個就是說
這家企業的收入
不應該小於一億美元
年收入一億美元
已經是一個非常大的體量
有這個體量的企業
它就已經進入了
一個叫做什麼呢
實力比較強
身體比較好
同時呢
市場影響力也比較大的一個階段
跨過這個門檻
你不要以為一億美元
一億美元很多企業是跨不過去的
絕大多數企業在
碰到一億美元就再也過不去了
能過去的
它就會進入一個良性的快速的發展階段
這個體量的企業
我們可以
預期
它每年有15%到20%左右的收入增速
這麼大的體量
如果說收入增速低於10%
我認為
它可能存在一些
動力不足的情況
發展可能就碰到了一個瓶頸
太高的增速
比如說40% 50%的這種增速的話
也很難維持
所以說
我認為
一億美元的年收入這種規模的企業
這個
它的成長性在15%到20%是比較理想
是一種可持續的狀態
接下去就是
看它的運營利潤率了
在同行業當中
同一種生意類型的企業當中
運營利潤率
越高越好
對吧
運營利潤率越高
它的這個
抗風險的空間就越大
彈性就越大
當然這個運營利潤率呢
是不可能
不可以跨行業比較的
不同的商業模式
它的利潤率是不同的
比如說谷歌可以做到32%的運營利潤率
但是沃爾瑪只有4%
但是你不能說
沃爾瑪的4%就一定比谷歌的32%要差
不是這樣的
因為它的商業模式是不同的
但是呢
我們可以用沃爾瑪的4%的運營利潤率
去和Costco的3.7%的運營利潤率做比較
這樣的一種比較
我們也看得出來
沃爾瑪的這個企業的這個運行效率
就要比Costco要高一點點
這種同業比較才有意義然後呢就是看運營現金流
我認為
運營現金流必須是正值
這表達你做生意是可以賺到錢的
運營現金流是負值
就說明你不掙錢
在運營現金流是正值的前提下
自由現金流最好也是正值
前面已經說了
自由現金流是一個企業
可以自由拿來
隨意做一些變動的
一些彈性的商業活動的
這樣的一個可能性
前面說到的這幾個財務數據呢
我們可以用來驗證一家企業
它的商業模式到底靠不靠譜
是不是已經走上了正軌
我這種篩選方式呢
也是刻意排除掉了那些
目前還停留在講故事階段的股票
如果是一個好企業
你的故事真的能夠成真的話
那我相信你終有一天
會跨過這個門檻
進入到我的股票池當中的
之前我有一個網友
他跟我討論一隻股票
這隻股票我看了一下
確實這隻股票
有很多很多的動聽的故事
又是什麼遠程醫療啦
又是這個AI概念啦
又是這個叫什麼
國會山股神佩洛西的持倉
但是呢你打開報表一看
這家公司是屬於結構性虧損的狀態
EBIT margin是小於零的
債務甚至大於收入
它完全沒有產生現金流的能力
如果像這樣的一家企業
那最近這個股票也走得比較弱
還跑不贏大盤
我不知道這位網友
他在賭什麼
對不對
在我的觀念當中
如果說一隻完全靠故事驅動的股票
一旦弱於大盤就必須要果斷拋棄了
那當然這是一個
另外一種叫做動量投資的策略
這個話題呢
我會找時間來專門做一個影片
來講一講這個動量投資的事情
當我們找到了靠譜的企業之後
我們就需要看它的市場定價
市場定價不是股價高低
而是指估值
所謂估值就是
我們常用的估值指標P/S P/E P/B
這些指標其實都在表達同一個意思
就是說這家企業的市場價值
和它的商業價值之間的關係
估值的意義在於
讓我們瞭解市場預期
相類似的企業當中呢
估值較高的企業說明
投資者給予的更高的預期
估值高有高的道理
低有低的道理
我們沒有必要去與它計較
我有一篇文章是專門講這個估值的
有興趣的朋友可以去看一下
總而言之
基本面並不需要
多麼深厚的財務基礎
有一些基本的商業邏輯的常識
你能夠掌握我前面說到的這些
幾個重要的內容就夠了
不是越多越好
基本面分析框架主要解決
一個定性的問題
但是呢
它不能夠解決具體操作的問題
我有一句名言叫做
基本面不可以用來做交易
因為有很多財務數據
看上去非常好的企業
它的股價可以一直跌的
所以說怎樣做交易
怎樣買入賣出這些事情
這就屬於是技術面的範疇
我們講技術面的範疇
或者技術面框架
主要看三個方面
趨勢 位置 和風險管理
我另外還有一個名言
多數時候我們賺的都是趨勢的錢
關於趨勢呢
我這裡有一個影片
做過詳細的講解
簡單的來說呢
我把價格趨勢分成五個時鐘方向來表示
1點鐘到12點鐘方向的趨勢方向
這表明市場對這個企業的生意
是極度看好
甚至有點瘋狂的
2點鐘左右的趨勢方向
它表達市場的認可度是比較高的
投資者是比較樂觀的
3點鐘方向
那很顯然就是一種猶豫啊
懷疑啊和不信任的一種態度
4點鐘方向的趨勢
表達市場不認可
比較悲觀
5點到6點鐘的這種方向
表達市場極度的
不相信或者不看好企業的商業前景
投資者極度悲觀
這樣的一種狀態
我們研究趨勢
所謂趨勢
趨勢的作用就在於
它是已知信息和未知信息之間的橋樑
舉個例子來說
我們看這家企業
它的收入持續增長
很不錯
對不對
經營現金流
自由現金流也很不錯
運營利潤率也保持一個比較高
比較穩定的水平
但是呢股價卻這段時間是
持續的下跌
P/S估值已經跌回到了
歷史最低水平的附近
股價和基本面朝著完全相反的方向運行
這說明有些事情
我們可能不知道
價格趨勢告訴我們
市場不看好這家企業的商業前景
像這樣的股票
我的經驗是
不要去抄底
暫時不要碰
至少要看到這個股價
這個逐漸往上
逐漸這個基本面和股價
能夠配合往上的時候
股價已經形成了一定的上漲趨勢之後
再進入
這樣的話呢
就是相對的安全
我會更傾向於
做這種兩點鐘方向趨勢
這種股票
基本面往這裡走
股價也是往這個方向走
這個基本面和股價相互驗證
同步上漲的股票
這樣的股票
有市場共識
拿得住
也是最容易賺到錢的一種方式
技術框架的第二個層面
就是位置
我們經常說
這個位置那個位置
所謂位置
就是一些歷史上
投資者關於這隻股票的
公允價格
我們一般的股票圖表上
橫軸是時間
縱軸是價格
成交量表達
此時市場參與者
對這個股票的看法
對不對
成交量
還有另外一種表達方式
就是縱向的
這個籌碼分佈
它表達的是
在選定的這個時間範圍之內
某一些價格上的
成交量的堆積
某個價格附近出現的
較大的這個成交量堆積
我們叫做籌碼峰
籌碼峰就是
說明這個地方
是有市場共識的
這個價格
有大量的人參與
有市場共識
籌碼峰越大
這個市場共識就越大
籌碼峰
就可以看作是
市場的公允價格
公允價格
通常會有阻力和支撐的作用
在上漲趨勢過程當中
價格回撤到
某一個重要的籌碼峰附近的時候
這裡往往會形成價格的支撐作用
下跌過程當中
當它反彈碰到某一個重要的
籌碼峰的時候呢
這裡可能會起到
一定的阻力的作用
這些重要的位置
其實就是可以用來
幫助我們判斷
這個位置
是可以買入或者賣出的位置
因為這裡有大量的市場共識
這個共識對我們來說
是相對安全的
前面我說
基本面不可以用來做交易
交易怎麼做
結合上面的籌碼
這些價格
我們來說一下
我的經驗是
第一
找到你喜歡的商業模式
找到一個
你認為靠譜的生意
股價最好是運行在兩點鐘方向
左右的方向
怎麼看
這個時間呢
我這裡有個影片
大家再去看一下
我這裡就不多說了
最重要的是
兩點鐘方向的趨勢
等它的股價回撤
它總是要回撤
對不對
你就耐心等就是了
等股價回撤到
重要的籌碼峰的附近
重要的供應價值的附近
買入
前提是什麼
它的總體的趨勢是往上的
兩點鐘方向
它的總體的
這個商業狀況
這個財務狀況
也是朝著這個方向
這種股票才可以做
當然了
圖形不是萬能的
圖形裡面有各種各樣的
這種錯誤信號
特別是某些小股票
流動性很差的
這個價格也容易被操縱
但是不管怎麼樣
無論如何
不管你是否看好這個企業
或者說是怎麼樣
你記住一句話
任何一筆交易
最重要的是
要有預期
很多人是有預期
沒錯
同時要有底線
所謂底線
就是我們的風險邊界
絕大多數人
在股市上的虧損
都是因為沒有底線導致的
或者說即使有底線
跌破底線也不肯認輸的結果
十幾年前
我也曾經犯過一次
這樣的重大的錯誤
損失慘重
當時我的股票
出現了持續下跌的情況
但是根據我當時的掌握的財務數據
各個方面的信息
以及我對這家股票
我自認為我對這家公司非常的瞭解
所以我堅持認為
我沒有錯
市場錯了
所以我硬扛了很長時間
還逢低加倉了很多
但是最終呢
連續兩個季度的財務數據
證明我看錯了
並且財報當中公佈了
企業管理層出現了嚴重的
或者說是明顯的
這種決策失誤
但是這種事情呢
我是無法從公開信息當中
及時獲得的
總之呢
最後是一個慘敗出局的結果
直到今天
這隻股票還沒有
漲回到我當初
忍痛割肉的位置
但是這件事情呢
對我形成了非常大的影響
它也成為了我投資生涯當中
最重要的一條教訓
就是說
當圖形與我的預期方向不一致的時候
我應該尊重圖形的方向
因為總有一些事情我不知道
然而圖形中
其實已經包含了這些信息了
總之
任何一筆交易
有預期
有底線
有計劃
最重要的是
依計行事
這個三有加一執行的原則
是打開財富之門的金鑰匙
它不僅用於
我們做投資
做股票
它同樣適用於
我們平時的做人做事
最後總結一下
企業基本面框架
用來定性
是一個值不值得參與
打不打得贏的一個戰略問題
如果這家
這家公司
這家企業
生意生意上有問題
不值得投資
你根本就不要考慮後面的事情
你就忽略
另外再找就好了
技術框架問題
它是用來指導
我們的具體交易的
是怎樣打贏的一個戰術問題
孫子兵法當中
有兩句經典
我分享給大家
第一句叫做
知可以戰與不可以戰者勝
第二句
善戰者勝於異勝者也
這兩句話
是我自己做投資
做交易
甚至做人做事的
最高指導原則
好就說這些
我們下期節目再見
拜拜